hey youtubers surprise surprise Game of
Thrones dropped another preview so I'm
going to break it down careful for
spoilers for everything that's happened
on the show so far there's so much to
get through but if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything I do Game of Thrones videos
every week there's a new round of the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so I'm just going to go through
each of these pictures one by one but
I'll start with the big stuff first you
may have noticed the Gilly is reading a
page with Samwell in the Citadel here
there's any number of things that he
could be researching but it's a really
cool thing about this is that she's
actually reading a page from the world
of Ice and Fire book like it's an actual
history book of Game of Thrones that you
can buy in real life to detail some of
the history George are Martin only wrote
part of it but this will drive you crazy
the page that she's reading is about
azor Ahai so they're learning all about
the prophecy of the prince who was
promised regards prophecy that you see a
lot of in the books but we haven't seen
too much of in the show you've heard
Melisandre talk about the one who was
promised but you haven't heard it
literally you've only heard Ozora High
and the one who was promised talked
about a little separately originally she
thought that it was Stannis now it
sounds like she believes that it's Jaws
snow even though Jon Snow doesn't want
to have anything to do with it and you
see Jon Snow's picture with him in the
crypts at Winterfell so maybe he will
learn more about Lyanna stark there's
any number of reasons for him to go down
into the crypts to just be with his
ancestors to try and draw strength from
his father but it would be really fun if
bran tried to send him visions and we
also see bran so I'll talk about his
picture in a second but it would be
really cool to see Jon Snow get visions
the way that bran got visions of the
three-eyed Raven so just starting to
think more and more about his heritage
the same way that Daenerys is thinking
more and more about her heritage as they
all roll up to Dragonstone so as the
nares of standing here with Tyrion grey
worm Varys and myths and I and the
unsullied behind them it's kind of hard
to tell where they are but then you see
the other pictures with her inside
Dragonstone with better pictures of the
throne room that you saw during the
teaser so it just helps connect some of
those dots so this is outside
Dragonstone they look like they just
made landfall and they're looking up at
it like it's this terrible Specter
something very grand and ominous that
did
Aires hasn't seen in a long long time
although she herself would not have
memories of it she was born there during
a really bad storm that's why they call
her Daenerys Stormborn
but typically infants don't retain a lot
of really clear memories till they're
about two years old by that time
Robert's rebellion was winding down so
she and Viserys had already made for the
east to try and hide out in exile but
there's this really interesting thing
you have going on in this picture here
where you have like half of the people
who know all about Dragonstone in the
other half who are experiencing it for
the first time like oh my god this is
this crazy place that I've heard so much
about but of all these people Barris has
the best look on his face like this is
all part of this plan he knows exactly
what's going to happen he's kind of like
the little finger of Daenerys Camp
albeit slightly less sinister someone
who has a master plan that he's bringing
to fruition in so far everything is
going according to that plan in Tyrians
look at just priceless - like oh my god
somebody get me some wine I'm not ready
for this it's going to get crazy so
fast I've talked a lot about all the new
costumes
the Targaryen costumes look the best you
get a much better look at them this is
varus's new costume this is Miss and I
look at the clasp on her cloak here it's
just a bunch of dragons eating each
other's tails
I love the dragon motif so rolling up in
Targaryen black so pay special attention
when you're looking at people's costumes
you just see like little bits of dragon
worked into it all over the place so the
colour itself is a Targaryen colour
black there's not a lot of red on their
clothing it's kind of subtle but
everybody has their own piece of dragon
jewelry in some way Tyrion has the hand
of the kingpin or we should say the hand
of the queen pin the variation from the
ones that they wear in King's Landing is
that this one is silver the one in
King's Landing that he along with all
the other hands of the king wore is gold
so I know it seems like the dark version
of the power structure in King's Landing
but arguably Daenerys is more of the
protagonist than Cersei is but I do love
the variation like it's a mirror of
what's going on in King's Landing
speaking of which we see Cersei and
Jaime in the red keep it looks like
she's just holding court in front of a
lot of people it'll be interesting to
see what the day-to-day is like in her
court
because you look at scenes like this and
it seems like everyone's scared of her
but nobody likes her so it's going to be
a really interesting situation in Jaime
is the commander
their army they're getting ready for a
really big battle so I don't know how
long she's going to have him to rely on
and he already seems pretty dubious
about what she's doing too like he's
growing more and more afraid of her as
well but the other big power structure
up in the north so they said all these
pictures are from season seven but it
almost looks like this little bear
picture with little finger back in the
background in the shadows looks directly
from this scene during the end of season
six but usually they do that in the
first episode at least the first couple
of scenes address some of the
consequences of what happened in the
previous season's finale before moving
forward so this looks like a
continuation of Jon Snow being named
king of the north or just everyone
rallying to his banner like okay we're
going to support your claim on the North
Isle of Davos sitting here at the table
it's almost like he's going to be hand
of the king in the north the way the
tyrion is the hand of the Queen in the
way the Qyburn is the hand of the Queen
in King's Landing
if you weren't sure about that Qyburn is
Circe's hand of the Queen and then we
got to talk about bran we see Meera
pulling bran closer to the wall there
was this funny thing to Ellie Kendrick
said just about how she's his protector
now because Hodor isn't around anymore
and he is heavy because the after the
plays brand is getting bigger and bigger
physically just as he gets older so it's
kind of a funny thing with them on set
but Issac Hempstead right the actor said
that they finished filming most of their
scenes relatively early last year so
just remains to be seen whether or not
he actually makes it south to Winterfell
but there are a number of ways that
we've talked about in my other videos
about how brand can communicate with the
people at Winterfell either sending them
visions or communicating through the
weirwood or even using snail mail raven
sending a physical message to them but
it sounds like if you're going to convey
something so important as to tell them
what your heritage is your father was
secretly a Targaryen then you would do
it in a more meaningful way than just a
simple letter but I love tormund
Giantsbane here just looking at Brienne
like he is not going to give up at all I
know some people want to see them
together it's not a Canon thing but it's
totally possible
I just love the chemistry that they have
together it's so funny when you consider
how crazy things are getting in the
narrative the drama is so intense that
it's always awesome to see moments like
this just a sly look from him and the
look of disgust from
Rianne because she's obviously still
stuck on Jamie but then sort of
overseeing all of what's going on in the
courtyard you have the sinister
Littlefinger in Santa that just looks
like she's taking it in her look is kind
of hard apart so this is almost
deceiving she's just keeping it all in
so that just implies that her character
isn't going to be wearing her emotions
on her sleeve the way she did the first
couple of seasons the young Sansa
learning to play the game of Thrones the
game of politicking in the way that
Littlefinger plays it so even though it
seems like they're pushing those two
characters together that doesn't mean
that she's going to be team Littlefinger
where she wouldn't throw them under the
bus at the first opportunity and then
you have the Hound in full furs with the
Brotherhood behind him heading to the
north so I know it seems like they're
very far north but you have to remember
that it's snowing pretty hard at
Winterfell right now so it looks like
they're headed in that direction so the
implication is that you will get a
reunion between the Hound and Brienne
before you get a reunion between Arya
and some of these characters because
even if she's making her way north it
still looks like she's relatively
further south but she's inside so it's
kind of hard to tell she could be in any
number of taverns in this picture but
let me know in the comments where do you
think that Arya is in this tavern here
if she's still in the Riverlands or has
she started to make her way north so I
know these pictures are kind of a tease
but they actually do convey a lot of
information a lot of people looking to
their heritage either in the crypts of
Winterfell or going to their home their
literal home in Dragonstone in a lot of
characters converging on each other like
the Hound and Brienne so what I'm
expecting is is that because we're
getting closer to the series actually
dropping when we get about two months
out we'll probably get that full
official trailer but leave all your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments below or any questions that you
have based on these pictures but there
was a funny interview that Kit Harington
did where he talked about the idea of
azor Ahai and how Jon Snow might react
to that idea being called the prince who
was promised so I might do a bonus video
on that next but leave all your requests
so I'll say congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Nino please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details you want to copy one of the
enhanced editions of the book and while
you wait for that next video you can
click here to learn all about the
history of Dragonstone and you can click
here for my Varys Season 7 video thank
you
so much for watching let's high-five
I'll see you guys in the next video
you